New York comic-con Marvel announced some
exciting news for anyone who likes
Marvel movies so pretty much everyone no
surprise here they're making more more
than they even said there'd be in the
first place they're calling it Marva get
it kidding no it's going to be phase
four phase four I like that it's going
to ring to it Paul Rudd fans rejoice
because they're gonna squeeze in a new
ant-man movie into Phase three
it's called ant-man and the wasp which
probably will be about ant-man and los
Evangeline Lilly this means that they're
gonna have to reship some other stuff in
Phase three so they're scooting up black
panther 2 February 16 2018 and pushing
Captain Marvel back to March 8 2019 and
that actually means Evangeline Lilly
gets to be the first female Marvel
superhero to get a movie named after her
Orko named after instead of Captain
Marvel
ohoho wasp first Captain Marvel catfight
anybody once your catfight what catfight
going on No
why is everything a catfight with you I
don't know could be because I was abused
by Kat wait what let's move on the other
release date news there revealed is much
more open-ended all we know is that
Marvel phase 4 set to start after
Avengers infinity war is all done now
has three official release dates in the
next couple of years
may 1st 2020 gel i-10 2020 and November
6 2020 wait since when did the distant
future of 2020 become in a couple of
years how time flies and we are just
mere morsels on the fabric of I was
hoping to come up with something more
poetic but nothing came to me let's just
wrap this up here are my burning
questions let me know what you think
about these in the comments below 1 what
storylines you think they're gonna
feature an ant-man and the wasp any
ideas on one that could tie a new
infinity war number two what freaking
movies are gonna come out on those dates
2020 I mean there's move I have female
alright what are you doing oh this is my
show I know you have a question I know
what movies are coming out of on those
dates I was asking them no I know but
like educated guess right just look at
the date and you'll actually see that a
couple of movies will be due for sequels
at that point think about the timing it
could easily be the next next guardians
movie because at that point it'll be due
for a sequel or it could also be
spider-man 2 because in 2020 that'll be
due for a sequel okay
but or uh dr. strange too because at
that point it'll be duper sequel
yeah absolutely yes or it could be
easily Iron Man for in that situation
it'll actually have a group residual no
no Robert Downey jr. contract is up but
I actually think they'll be able to get
him back I just don't know what
storyline that end up doing they might
actually end up actually doing the real
Mandarin storyline River we're all very
impressed are you done no the Hulk the
Hulk could finally get his Marvel movie
maybe Planet Hulk great that that could
be one of the four awesome
could I have my mic back thank you why
don't you go do your own show and I'll
finish mine
thank you fill up leave a comment okay
all these questions or or action or Nova
they might do Nova movie he's like
Marvel's Green Lantern kind of yeah I
knew that
cool I'll finish up here I can take no
no no no I'm get hurt no I'm Gipper
writer your fill up and you'll finish a
different show alright guys sorry about
him let us know your thoughts and
questions about the ant-man in the loss
story and the unnamed phase for movies
and subscribe for more quick hashtag
news updates and also our upcoming
pretty exciting shows that I can't
actually tell you about because most
still listening flood coma no no no I'll
just tuck no I don't need you female
we're good I'm gonna finish it I go bye
that's it
Jimin is a boy that's nice at the end of
my video yeah